[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue et bonjour on suit ce mardi
matin du 9 mai le défilé militaire russe
et qui sera bientôt suivi du discours de
Vladimir Poutine qui est forcément très
attendu on vous le fera suivre on vous
fera suivre en commentaire en traduit
bien évidemment et je suis avec Fabrice
bonjour Fabrice bonjour Vincent ancien
correspondant du Figaro à Moscou on le
voit Vladimir Poutine sur cet estrade
qui s'apprête à parler dans un contexte
toujours attendu bien sûr puisque ça
fait plus d'un an que la guerre en
Ukraine a débuté déjà une première
question là-bas célébration de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale se passe le 9
mai oui le 9 mai est pas le 8 mai comme
dans le dans le reste de l'Europe c'est
à l'origine une question de décalage
horaire en fait la capitulation a été
signée par les Allemands à Berlin alors
qu'il était le 23h16 heures locales lors
de l'Ouest le 8 mai à Berlin il était
déjà minuit 16 à Moscou en fait c'était
une seconde reddition il y en avait eu
une première signée à Reims le 7 Staline
n'était pas content il voulait
absolument qu'il y ait un acte signé à
Berlin donc c'était déjà les prémices de
des divisions de la guerre froide et
justement dans la suite de ces prémices
de la guerre froide Staline a toujours
voulu marquer la différence et fêter dès
l'après-guerre la victoire de la grande
guerre patriotique comme on l'appelle en
appelant en URSS et comme on a continué
à l'appeler dans la Russie de yelsini
puis de Poutine de la fêter le 9 mai et
non le 8 mai donc une date très
symbolique on en reparlera tout à
l'heure avec le choix de l'Ukraine à ce
sujet bien sûr voilà vous n'hésitez pas
tout au long de ce live bien sûr à poser
vos questions je salue Christian Léon
Toussaint qui est avec nous dans le chat
du Figaro je salue aussi tous ceux qui
nous suivent sur Youtube vous n'hésitez
pas donc à poser vos questions on va
parler de de ce défiler on va on va
suivre ça le 9 mai ça a une grande
importance on va essayer vous qui a été
correspondant là-bas c'est c'est
quasiment la fête nationale même si
officiellement ce n'est pas la fête
nationale mais pendant toute soviétique
c'était vraiment une date extrêmement
importante avec donc ce défilé militaire
cette démonstration de force qui a lieu
sur la Place Rouge donc le lieu
l'incarnation du pouvoir soviétique puis
russe et dans la
dans la ferveur populaire aussi ça a été
très longtemps et ça le reste encore
très largement une fête très importante
où on se souvient des sacrifices
absolument immenses consenties par le
peuple les peuples soviétiques et russes
durant le second conflit mondial puisque
je vous rappelle alors les Chi est
toujours des polémiques sur les chiffres
mais il y a sans doute plus de 25 26
millions de citoyens de l'Union
soviétique qui sont morts pendant la
Seconde Guerre mondiale donc appelé par
Staline la grande guerre patriotique qui
permettait un peu d'oublier les débuts
de la guerre puisqu'il y a eu d'abord le
pacte Germano soviétique au tout début
avant que Hitler ne se retourne vers
l'URSS en 1941 et que Staline lance
toutes ses forces dans la bataille et
soit un allié absolument déterminant
c'est un peu leur 14 juillet à eux oui
oui clairement c'est le plus grand
défilé militaires de l'année très
spectaculaire il y a évidemment on parle
cette année de quelques dix mille hommes
qui défileraient à Moscou parce qu'il y
a eu quelques défilés en province même
si on a moins nombreux c'est souvent une
démonstration de d'engins militaires de
blindés de missile même des missiles
pouvant nucléaire transporter des têtes
nucléaires évidemment les têtes
nucléaires ne sont pas sur la place
rouge mais les missiles de la force
stratégique nucléaire sont en général
conviés à ce défilé il y a selon les
années un défilé aérien aussi très très
important très spectaculaire il avait
été annulé l'an dernier officiellement
pour cause de mauvaises météo alors que
là il a l'air de faire beau et vous me
disiez que bizarrement le 9 mai il fait
toujours très beau à Moscou alors je
sais pas si c'est de la légende urbaine
c'est quelque chose qui est très
longtemps été répété à l'époque
soviétique et en tout cas au début de
l'air Poutine
on disait que les Russes utilisaient en
semant cèdent des nuages de avec de
celle d'iodure d'argent une technique
connue depuis des décennies pour
éclaircir le ciel sur un périmètre bien
déterminé
a priori c'est une technique qui a été
après à plusieurs reprises utilisées et
très souvent effectivement les 9 mai
bénéficiaient d'un ciel bien bleu
au-dessus de la Place Rouge les Chinois
paraît-il aussi utilisent ce genre de
technique pour garantir un bon un bouton
on voit le ministre de la Défense
Sergueï dans un commande car qui vient
de saluer qui est bien présent oui qui
était au début de la fin au début de la
guerre on le voyait énormément puis
après on l'a plus vu pendant un moment
il s'était il avait été escamoté pour
des raisons toujours mystérieuses faut
être extrêmement prudent dès lors qu'on
essaye de donner des explications pour
tout ce qui concerne la décision du
Kremlin encore plus depuis le début de
la guerre il y a beaucoup de fausses
informations
tenues secrètes
qu'on parle souvent de proche de Poutine
pour le coup lui est un vrai proche un
intime de Poutine donc avait semble-t-il
été écarté sanctionné difficile à dire
et puis il était réapparu
donc ministre de la Défense que l'on
voit ici à l'image alors si on disait ça
ressemble à notre 14 juillet un 14
juillet nous on invite des chefs d'État
de tous les de de tous les pays là on a
vu le captainco le le président
des alliés les plus proches ou même du
village plus qu'un allié
certains diraient
un suppo de
inféodé à Vladimir Poutine donc
Alexandre le coach & Co le président
dictateur de la Biélorussie Biélorussie
qui a été utilisé notre pays voisin
aussi de l'Ukraine qui a été utilisé par
les troupes russes pour pour pouvoir
attaquer dans la première période de
l'offensive dans la région de Kiev mais
sinon des des chefs d'État on imagine
mal le prix américain ou des grands
présidents venir s'en faire un jour aux
prises alors en 2020 Vladimir Poutine
avait eu le souhait l'ambition pour
marquer le 75e anniversaire de de la
victoire sur l'Allemagne nazie de
convier tous les grands chefs d'État
c'était prévu et puis c'est le covid le
virus qui a empêché ce grandiose cette
grandiose réunion et du coup cette année
évidemment les pays que Moscou qualifie
de non Namiko ne sont pas conviés il y a
quelques chefs d'État des pays proches
des chefs d'État d'Asie centrale vous
lisiez tout à l'heure Alexandre
lucaschenko
voilà c'est de l'essentiel des chefs
d'État représentés effectivement et on
se demande aussi le public on a bien
cette publicité comme vous qui avez été
comment ça se passe alors
traditionnellement en tout cas à
l'époque où j'étais qui remonte
maintenant il y a une quinzaine d'années
sur la Place Rouge même il n'y avait pas
de grand public c'était vraiment des
invités triés sur le volet donc beaucoup
de vétérans tant il y en avait encore
des vétérans de la grande guerre
patriotique souvent bardé de médailles
ils sont très très impressionnantes très
émouvants et puis le gratin je dirais de
la société russe évidemment des élus des
quelques hommes d'affaires les gens du
monde du spectacle mais le grand public
le général était relié dans la rue pour
pouvoir une partie du défilé les
véhicules arrivés mais il n'était pas
convié pour des raisons de sécurité dans
ces tribunes qu'on voit qui font dos aux
murailles rouges du Kremlin et la presse
internationale était
traditionnellement conviés j'ai eu
personnellement la chance de d'assister
à ce défiler très spectaculaire à deux
reprises cette année
les pays donc toujours qualifiés de non
amicaux et la France en fait partie ne
sont pas conviés donc Alain barluel
notre correspondant à Moscou n'est pas
cette année sur la Place Rouge il pourra
pas il ne pourra pas suivre ce
défilé donc
il y a quelque chose dans dans des films
ça s'appelle le régiment immortel alors
c'est une tradition qui
a été plus plus moins spontanément
généré dans les années 2005-2010 en fait
et alors là pour le coup c'est les gens
de la population le public qui a
commencé à défiler dans les rues avec
des portraits de leur chair disparus
encore une fois je rappelle ce chiffre
absolument incroyable de plus de 25
millions de morts soviétiques pendant le
la Seconde Guerre mondiale et donc des
familles défilaient avec le portrait à
la main de leur disparu Vladimir Poutine
avait récupéré cette cette idée
populaire il a lui-même défilé sauf
erreur de ma part avec le portrait de
son père
et Vladimir Poutine pas passer son
enfance il est né après la Seconde
Guerre mondiale au début des années 50
mais il est né dans un liningrad encore
très très marquée par le siège terrible
donc liningrad devenu Saint-Pétersbourg
marqués par un siège absolument terrible
pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale et
donc Vladimir Poutine avait récupéré ce
qu'on a appelé le défilé des immortels
on brandit les photos des disparues ces
défilé n'a pas été semble-t-il autorisé
cette année on peut penser qu'il y a une
crainte de la part des autorités que
certaines familles brandissent les
portraits des disparus dans les conflits
en Ukraine vous savez que les autorités
russes entourent le nombre de victimes
militaires d'un très grand secret il y a
les services secrets
occidentaux qui avancent des chiffres
c'est très difficile de savoir on parle
de plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
morts peut-être de soldats russes depuis
février 2022 mais on en sait absolument
rien et en tout cas les autorités les
autorités russes n'ont absolument aucune
envie qu'on voit des portraits des des
soldats russes disparus en une crainte
dans la rue ça pourrait se retourner
contre le pouvoir même si Vladimir
Poutine a quand même à cœur de souligner
l'héroïsme soldats envoyés dans cette
opération spéciale opération spéciale
toute l'ambiguïté du terme toujours une
opération spéciale ça n'a pas changé
depuis on parle toujours d'opération
spéciale et donc cette opération
spéciale n'est pas censée faire des
dizaines de milliers de victimes alors
on parlait tout à l'heure de la de la
sécurité sur cette plage rouge on
imagine que ça doit être il faut
sécuriser alors que le lien Poutine
devrait prendre la parole d'ici quelques
instants la place Rouge a été fermée
pendant 15 jours avant c'est tout à fait
inhabituel de temps en temps fermé au
public pendant quelques jours là on voit
le ministre
de la défense saluer Vladimir Poutine
qui va parler un discours qui va nous
être traduit par notre interprète Olga
peut-être une minute de silence avant
et donc effectivement
parler de la sécurité
c'était même ces dispositifs on va
écouter Vladimir Poutine de la Russie
Gervais des rang
les participants à l'opération spéciale
militaires je vous félicite à l'occasion
de cette fête du jour de la victoire
c'est la fête pour commémorer nos pères
nos grands
leur nom et sont devenus immortels en
défendant leur patrie
grâce alors sacrifice alors courage ils
ont sauvé la patrie du nazisme
aujourd'hui notre civilisation se trouve
une nouvelle fois en tournant entre
notre patrie on a déclenché une
véritable guerre
mais nous nous avons résisté au
terrorisme international nous allons
aussi
protéger les citoyens du gambas et nous
allons assurer notre sécurité pour nous
pour les Russes il n'y a pas de peuple
inamico ni en Occident
nous voulons voir l'avenir paisible
libre et stable
de suprématie par sa nature et
dégoûtante et criminels et mortifères
mais les élites occidentales
pense toujours à leur caractère
exceptionnel il s'aime la discorde entre
les peuples et les nations et provoquent
des conflits des coûts il provoque le
nationalisme agressif il nie les valeurs
traditionnelles familiales qui font de
l'homme un humain ils font tout pour
continuer à dicter au peuple leur
volonté
leur règle leur droit mais en fait c'est
un système de dépression et de violence
ils ont oublié les
conseils nazis ils ont oublié qui a
écrasé ce mal global qui n'a pas épargné
leur vie pour libérer les peuples de
l'Europe
nous voyons comme dans un certain nombre
de pays
avec du sang froid on détruit les
statues et les
statues dressés en mémoire du combattant
soviétique ils ont oublié la gloire des
vrais héros et
en réalité
ce sacrifice cette exploit et c'est un
crime
c'est un rêventisme
sans couverts de ceux qui ont préparé
entre la Russie ils ont rassemblé tous
les néonazis du monde entier il n'y a
rien de nouveau ils veulent arriver à
l'écrasement de la Russie de rayer ce
qu'il y a été atteint par le bilan de la
seconde guerre mondiale donc ils vont à
l'encontre de la sécurité internationale
international ils veulent détruire les
centres souverains du développement il
se croit tout permis et je vous assure
cela mène toujours à une tragédie et
c'est ça la raison de la tragédie de la
catastrophe du peuple
ukrainien qui sont devenus
otages du coup d'État c'est un régime
criminel à qui Ève elle est maître sont
en Occident ils ont des plans et sont
corrompus pour nous la mémoire des
défensions de la patrie et sacré et nous
la commémorons aujourd'hui nous pensons
aux participants au mouvement de
résistance qui ont combattu le nazisme
nous pensons aussi aux armées alliées
des États-Unis de la Grande-Bretagne et
d'autres pays nous nous souvenons de
l'exploit des Chinois dans cette
bataille contre le militarisme
la coopération la solidarité pendant ces
années c'est un
héritage c'est une mémoire et
aujourd'hui
nous voyons qu'il y a un mouvement dans
le monde vers un monde multiple polaire
ok basé sur les principes de la sécurité
indivisibles sur un développement libre
de tous les pays et de tous les peuples
il est important qu'aujourd'hui à Moscou
nous avons des leaders des pays de la
Communauté des États indépendants j'y
vois
un geste un signe
de commémorer la mémoire de nos ancêtres
ces peuples ont combattu ensemble tous
ces peuples de l'URSS sont convaincus
ensemble et ont contribué à cette grande
victoire nous allons toujours nous en
souvenir et nous nous inclinons devant
la mémoire de tous qui ont perdu leur
vie à cette guerre devant la mémoire des
fils des filles des pères des mers des
grands-pères des maris des femmes des
frères des sœurs
de tous les proches de les amis
je vous demande d'observer une minute de
silence
merci
pour le destin de notre patrie sont
toujours devenues sacrés populaires
et nous allons poursuivre les combats de
nos ancêtres nous on prenons ce que cela
veut dire d'être à la hauteur de ce
qu'ils ont réussi à faire nous sommes
fiers des participants de l'opération
militaire spéciale de tout ce qui sont
en première ligne qui est aussi
l'arrière sur et travail il n'y a rien
de plus précieux actuellement que votre
travail au combat
la sécurité du pays dépend de vous
l'avenir de notre état et de notre
peuple et où vous accomplissez votre
devoir militaire vous combattez pour
l'avenir de la Russie pour vos familles
pour vos amis il vous attendent je suis
sûr que vous comprenez et vous ressentez
leur
sans fin pour le pays est derrière vous
pour soutenir nos héros nous prions pour
vous
camarades
aujourd'hui dans chaque famille on
glorifier les participants de la grande
guerre patriotique on pense aux proches
on porte les fleurs
ont différents
se souvient en les drogénins de Youri
militaires de 19
aujourd'hui nous voyons ici les
participants de l'opération militaire
spécial ce sont les personnes mobilisées
se sont aussi les personnes qui font
partie des unités de denisque ce sont
aussi les membres de la garde nationale
du ministère des urgences et d'autres
unités je vous salue tous ceux qui
combattent pour la Russie sur le champ
de combat tous ceux qui se trouvent
aujourd'hui
la grande guerre patriotique nos
ancêtres héroïques ont démontré qu'il
n'y a rien de plus fort que notre unité
dans le monde il y a rien de plus fort
que notre amour sont la patrie à la
Russie
nos forces armées glorieuse à la
victoire aura
[Musique]
bon les coups de canon qui partent après
le discours de Vladimir Poutine un
discours
qu'on attendait un peu ça ressemble un
peu à la suite de l'an dernier
finalement oui d'ailleurs on peut se
poser la question est-ce que l'an
dernier Vladimir Poutine s'imaginer que
12 mois plus tard cette opération
militaire spéciale comme il l'a encore
qualifié refusant absolument de parler
de guerre en Ukraine est-ce qu'il
s'imaginait que il ces troupes seraient
encore embourbées en Ukraine vous
souvenez du début fulgurant de
l'offensive on a pensé et beaucoup de
d'experts
occidentaux compris on pensait que Kiev
tomberait en quelques jours et puis on
connaît l'histoire maintenant une
résistance même une contre-offensive à
la fin de l'été dernier avec la reprise
notamment de Gerson une nouvelle
contre-offensive dont on parle beaucoup
c'est toujours
éventuellement dangereux de parler trop
à l'avance d'opérations militaires mais
en tout cas au 15e mois de guerre
l'armée russe et toujours
coincé en Ukraine le front et
relativement stabilisé sur 800 km
et donc Vladimir Poutine une deuxième
fois préside un défilé du 9 mai qui
célèbre la victoire comme nous disons
tout à l'heure contre l'Allemagne nazie
contre la victoire de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale
et donc il a évidemment fait allusion à
ce qui se passe en Ukraine mais encore
une fois en toujours qualifiant cette
guerre d'opérations militaire spéciale
il a rendu un hommage appuyé au
combattant disons que le peuple était
était derrière eux et puis il a
entretenu effectivement comme l'an
dernier ça va mal la confusion entre le
combat de de
1941-1945 et le combat d'aujourd'hui en
qualifiant une fois de plus le régime
ukrainien de nazi
même que l'élite mondialisée occidentale
était perméable à cette idéologie nazie
il a d'ailleurs fait le distinguo entre
le peuples occidentaux en disant qu'il
n'y a pas de peuple inamico mais il s'en
est pris aux élites occidentales
mondialisés qui se
ourirait un grand complot contre la
survie de la Russie oui ils nous ont
pris en otage le peuple et lui a dit ils
ont oublié qui a écrasé l'Allemagne les
questions aussi de les de les de les de
les prévenir en fait de ce que pourrait
faire la Russie oui alors moi je n'ai
pas lu le discours comme comme
explicitement menaçant il a eu des
discours plus plus menaçants au cours de
ces 15 derniers mois là on est vraiment
dans alors déjà c'est un message adressé
avant tout au peuple russe pour dire
toute la nation doit être derrière les
troupes russes contre contre cette
coalition occidentale dévoyée mondialisé
qui qui en veut
qui défend elle les vrais valeurs
les vraies valeurs chrétiennes notamment
même s'il n'a pas prononcé Sauveur de ma
part ce terme il a eu un petit mot aussi
pour la Chine lors de l'ordre du
discours il a eu
il a pas beau il a pas cité beaucoup de
pays mais par contre il a cité la Chine
oui c'est intéressant parce que c'est
vrai que dans l'imaginaire occidentale
dans la façon dont nous-même à l'école
avons appris l'histoire de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale on parle pas tellement
de la Chine qui avait été envahi par le
Japon et après qui a commencé sa guerre
civile à la fin de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale mais souvent on oublie que la
Chine finalement était dans le camp
allié même si tout la situation était
quand même confuse et la Vladimir
Poutine effectivement à rappeler le rôle
de la Chine dans le second conflit
mondial la Chine qui est effectivement
un allié en tout cas un ami comme le
revendique teasing evladimir Poutine a
mis indéfectible de la Russie
il a souligné par la présence de chefs
d'État de la Communauté des États
indépendants des Pays d'Aix URSS on a pu
voir donc en majesté je dirais Alexandre
lucaschenko le président biélorus et
puis il y a aussi le entre autres le
Premier ministre arménien
qui est dans une situation
monsieur pachinian qui est dans une
école pachinian qui est dans une
situation assez délicate puisque son
pays est en guerre avec l'Azerbaïdjan
qui veut reconquérir la province du
carabaque la Star Ac comme les les
Arméniens et
l'Arménie se sent bien seul et on a
d'autres choix que de se reposer sur son
allié traditionnel et historique la
Russie oui parce que on se rappelle au
moment du de ce conflit
en fin 2020 début 2021 c'est la Russie
qui était venue
bloquer les positions figer les
positions et on s'imagine que maintenant
qu'il s'occupait avec les
d'autant que l'Azerbaïdjan aussi n'est
pas clairement dans le camp occidental
il y a un jeu bien bien complexe là avec
le rôle de de la Turquie qui est
l'Allier de l'Azerbaïdjan qui me manque
de l'OTAN mais avec une position
extrêmement ambiguë dans le conflit
ukrainien donc un jeu complexe c'est le
premier ministre Nicole pachini en
premier ministre de l'Arménie présent
sur la Place Rouge je pense dans une
situation très inconfortable alors vous
êtes de plus en plus nombreux à nous
suivre vous n'hésitez pas bien sûr à
poser vos questions je les fabriquer à
côté de moi on le rappelle qui a vécu
qui qui a été correspondant pour Le
Figaro en Russie on a symphonique
inhumain il y a quand même pas mal de
soldats sur la Place Rouge ce sont ses
réserves on pourrait se demander
effectivement ça alors vous savez que
l'armée russe en terme d'effectif est
quand même l'une des plus plus grandes
du monde et donc mobiliser quelques dix
mille hommes même si parmi
il peut y avoir certaines troupes
d'élite ça ne va pas dégarnir le le
front ukrainien l'armée russe a
suffisamment de de profondeur pour se
permettre se défiler
très très massif on parle de 10000
hommes présents aujourd'hui à Moscou ce
qui n'empêche pas effectivement d'avoir
des dizaines de milliers d'hommes
mobilisés sur ce long front on le disait
tout à l'heure 800 km de front du nord
au sud de l'Ukraine feront relativement
figés mais mais où les opérations
continuent puisqu'il y a régulièrement
même quotidiennement des tirs de part et
d'autre des tirs de d'artillerie des
tirs de drones dans les deux sens dans
une situation extrêmement tendue ces
derniers jours il faut aussi à sécuriser
ce défilé parce que ça c'était la grande
crainte forcément de la Russie c'est
d'arriver à voir un défi militaire
complètement sécurisé oui bien sûr on se
souvient cette mystérieuse explosion
nocturne sur un dôme du Kremlin donc
quelques dizaines de mètres derrière la
tribune où se tient aujourd'hui Vladimir
Poutine une explosion sur un le palais
du Sénat dans l'enceinte du Kremlin la
semaine dernière que l'on a attribué à
des drones alors là aussi il y a
beaucoup de mystères c'est extrêmement
difficile de de
connaître les faits dans ce genre
d'histoire bien sûr la TAC de drone a
été attribuée aux
Ukrainiens ou à des forces soutenues par
l'Ukraine c'est si c'était le cas c'est
très inquiétant pour la sécurité du
Kremlin puisqu'on pense que c'est a
priori une des zones un des périmètres
les mieux défendus en Russie en même
temps c'est ces explosions n'ont créé
aucun dégât beaucoup de mystères mais en
tout cas ça ravivait l'attention
effectivement sur les enjeux de sécurité
autour du président russe est-ce que en
Ukraine on fêtait on fait toujours le 9
mai alors c'est une question très
importante et en fait volo dure Zelenski
vient de faire une annonce à ce sujet
jusqu'ici
l'Ukraine ancienne république soviétique
c'était aligné à la Russie et célébrait
le jour de la victoire contre
l'Allemagne nazie le 9 mai et non lui
mai on le disait en début d'émission
pourquoi le 9 mai c'est une histoire de
décalage horaire il était déjà le 9 mai
minuit passé lors de la signature de la
reddition à Berlin et Staline a toujours
voulu conserver cette date du 9 mai pour
se distinguer des alliés occidentaux
l'Ukraine était aligné sur cette date et
volody Zelinski dans un acte très
symbolique vient d'annoncer hier qu'il
voulait désormais fêter la victoire sur
l'Allemagne nazie le 8 mai comme le
reste de l'Europe et le 9 mai
sera consacré à célébrer l'Europe c'est
le cas donc dans l'Union européenne et
autres gestes très symbolique la
présidente de la Commission européenne
Ursula fander Leyen et présenta Kiev
aujourd'hui 9 mai jour de célébration de
l'Europe dans l'Union européenne je
crois que c'est la cinquième visite de
la présidente de la Commission
européenne acquief depuis le début du
conflit effectivement vous voyez ce
défilé qui se poursuit vous avez entendu
les murs Poutine qui a parlé alors on se
rappelle il fait des discours il peut
faire des discours assez longs là pour
un pour pour Cdiscount par contre ça
dure une dizaine de minutes oui il a
fait à peu près aussi court que que
l'année dernière
encore une fois il n'a pas eu de
discours en tout cas que moi je qualifie
de menaçant il y a plutôt entretenu donc
là la flamme de la victoire contre
l'Allemagne nazie il a entretenu la
confusion
avec le régime
ukrainien qu'il qualifie aussi de nazi
mais un discours effectivement assez
court et il veut laisser la place au
défilé donc qui est la grande parade
militaire annuelle en Russie toujours
très spectaculaire dans cet écran
sublime de la Place Rouge la place Rouge
effectivement vous avez vécu c'est c'est
défilé c'est quand même très
impressionnant bien sûr
notre défilé du 14 juillet sur les
Champs-Élysées est aussi
est aussi très très spectaculaire mais
là on a on a ce rassemblement des
troupes concentrées sur la Place Rouge
les têtes toujours tournées les soldats
se tournent vers la tribune officielle
vous les voyez ils tournent la tête à
droite
et puis il va y avoir tout dans quelques
instants les défilés motorisés des
engins blindés parfois des évidemment
des chars et puis des engins porteurs de
missiles parfois longue portée donc
vraiment une démonstration de force et
puis en principe il y a un défilé aérien
qui avait été annulé l'an dernier
mais en principe il est annoncé cette
année alors il y a aussi une autre
particularité de défiler c'est les
hourras qui sont ensemble ils ont
entendu un peu tout à l'heure on les a
entendu juste à l'issue du discours de
Vladimir Poutine oui trois ouras sonores
lancés par toutes les troupes présentes
c'est extrêmement impressionnant alors
on a eu une variante samedi au palais de
Buckingham de la part des troupes
anglaises britanniques pardon rassemblés
pour le couronnement du roi Charles III
là c'est une version un peu plus festive
chez les Britanniques ils font un
et la version russe est vraiment très
martiale très impressionnant quand on
l'entend quand on est sur place comme
c'était mon cas il y a une quinzaine
d'années
très très impressionnant alors j'ai une
question dans les commentaires sur les
sur les sanctions qui qui touchent la
Russie en plus c'est maintenant votre
votre domaine de prédilection maintenant
c'est sur cette extension russe on
parlait au début de la guerre des
sanctions qui pouvaient complètement
faire plier le régime russe finalement
ça n'a pas été le cas non alors les
faire plier
assécher les finances du régime russe
c'était l'objectif revendiqué par
l'Union européenne les États-Unis le
Canada le Japon les
occidentaux
on sait dans dans des exemples
historiques les sanctions
ça prend beaucoup de temps à fonctionner
et puis surtout des sanctions ça ne peut
être efficace que si quasiment tous les
pays ils prennent pas or la Russie a un
certain nombre de partenaires
d'envergure qui ne prennent pas de
sanction la Chine l'Inde le Brésil
quasiment tous les pays les briques les
pays d'Asie centrale qui sont
aujourd'hui représentés et donc il y a
un contournement assez massif des
sanctions par exemple on sait que il y a
le commerce certains importations ont
énormément augmenté dans des pays tels
que la Petite Arménie telle que le
Kazakhstan qui ensuite réexporte un
certain nombre de biens notamment
électroniques visées par les sanctions
les réexporte vers la Russie on sait que
l'Inde a acheté beaucoup plus de pétrole
russe cette année à des prix d'ailleurs
cassés donc c'est intéressant pour les
deux partenaires la Russie arrive à
écouler son pétrole et l'Inde arrive à
en acheter moins cher la Chine continue
d'échanger avec avec la Russie donc les
sanctions pour l'instant
ne fonctionne pas certainement aussi
bien que nous l'aurait souhaité certains
occidentaux dire qu'elles ne
fonctionnent pas du tout ce serait
exagéré on sait qu'il y a eu quand même
quelques problèmes d'approvisionnement
dans l'industrie automobile une partie
de l'année que les circuits financiers
sont beaucoup plus compliqués qu'une
partie des plusieurs dizaines de
milliards de dollars et d'euros des
avoirs de la Banque centrale russe sont
gelées donc les choses quand même plus
compliquées mais ce n'est pas l'asphyxie
tel que pouvait l'espérer certains
occidentaux et toute façon ça prendra du
temps l'idée et d'affaiblir sur le long
terme l'économie russe pour qu'elle ait
de plus en plus de mal à financer sa
guerre oui comme vous le disiez tout à
l'heure c'est pas de la part des
accidentaux parce que tous les pays
émergents comme le Brésil Lula est un
allié de la Russie oui c'est ce que ce
que je vous disais et donc la Russie
peut compter sur des alliés de poids qui
qui ressemble pèse pour sans doute plus
de la moitié
du PIB mondial
on continue de suivre ce défiler c'est
c'est c'est
cosaque semble-t-il c'est trop papiers
après effectivement il y a le défilé
motorisé et ça ça aussi c'est toujours
le grand parce que ça c'est quelque
chose alors motorisé on a ça en France
mais par contre des missiles comme en
Russie on ne le voit pas
il y a des missiles quand même de
longue portée de missiles motorisées qui
sont qui défilent sur les Champs-Élysées
me semble-t-il certaines années en
France mais en Russie c'est
effectivement
une des composantes de ce défilé
militaire d'avoir ces énormes camions
chargés de deux trois quatre missiles
notamment les missiles S400 qui ont
déporté de plusieurs centaines voire de
milliers de kilomètres qui sont donc des
lanceurs mobiles
compliqué à localiser à détruire pour la
part d'un adversaire et il est probable
qu'on devrait les voir
on aura les voir alors ça renvoie la
menace nucléaire que que Vladimir
Poutine a plusieurs reprises brandi des
débuts du conflit on sait que son allié
apparemment lui aurait
fixé une ligne rouge en disant attention
ne pas utiliser
l'harmonucléaire dans ce conflit parce
que ça entraînerait une escalade
absolument terrifiante
donc pour l'instant c'est plus de la
rhétorique oui on se rappelle que assez
tôt dans le dans le dans le début du
conflit il en avait parlé on parlait de
possibilités alors que là voilà ça c'est
le début des de la part du du défilé
motorisé on peut voir ses chars qui ont
l'air assez ancien oui on sait qu'il y a
encore beaucoup de chars de l'époque
soviétique qui qui servent en Ukraine
mais il y a aussi des char plus moderne
l'artillerie qui qui est vraiment
utilisé comme dans les guerres anciennes
dans cette guerre en Ukraine et on sait
l'importance que l'Ukraine a attaché à
pouvoir recevoir des chars
occidentaux chars qui commencent à
arriver sur le terrain à qui qui devrait
compter dans l'offensive même si on sait
que en face la Russie a vraiment
fortifié ses positions et que ce sera
très compliqué pour une offensive
blindée de franchir toutes tous ces
fortifications ces zones minées ces
fausses et creuser
donc la contre-offensive sera forcément
extrêmement compliqué pour pour les
Ukrainiens si elle a lieu s'il a eu
forcément
on parlait effectivement de ces
livraisons d'armes très importantes pour
l'Ukraine sachant que pour le coup
l'armée ukrainienne non à la base était
équipé avec les mêmes modèles que la
Russie oui alors elle avait commencé à
acquérir du matériel
occidental quand même depuis quelques
années
il y avait une volonté
de Kiev de rallier l'OTAN et de
moderniser son armée avec d'autres
fournisseurs que le seul russe mais la
base de son armée était effectivement
largement pourvu en équipement
soviétique en tout cas russe les caméras
dans les dans les véhicules comme on
peut le voir aussi lors des lors des
défilés du 14 juillet aussi on rappelle
ce parallèle même si vous le dis aussi
le défi du 14 juillet c'est très long
alors que un défilé un défilé comme
celui-ci
un peu plus ramassé ne serait-ce qu'à
cause de la géographie il y a pas tous
les Champs-Élysées à descendre
mais en tout cas ça reste un spectacle
une démonstration de force tout à fait
impressionnante et
c'est une date encore une fois c'est
presque l'équivalent de la fête
nationale même si officiellement ce
n'est pas la fête nationale
pour pour les Russes c'est une date une
commémoration extrêmement importante le
souvenir de sacrifice des quelques 25
millions de citoyens soviétiques pendant
le second conflit mondial a été très
entretenu pendant toute la période
stalinienne puis le reste de l'époque
soviétique puis par Vladimir Poutine et
que ça reste important pas une famille
russe n'a été épargnée par par le
confine mondial alors vous voyez un
petit plan sur la machinerie qui fait
tourner les les roues là vous avez pu
vous allez plus vous avez pu le voir
avec ce défilé qui se poursuit on voit
des gens on a vu d'ailleurs pendant ce
défiler aussi des des jeunes garçons des
jeunes filles très jeunes filles très
jeune garçon habillée en habit oui
toujours eu une mise en scène même bien
avant le conflit en Ukraine de jeunes
alors ça peut être des cadets ou là
c'était même des enfants plutôt d'âge
d'être à l'école primaire mettant des
des
uniformes de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
en hommage à leurs aïeux tombés pendant
le conflit il y a un côté
instrumentalisation bien sûr
en brièvement de des enfants vous savez
que les programmes scolaires sont
surveillés de très très près que
cette histoire de cette jeune fille de
12-13 ans qui dont le père a été arrêté
parce qu'elle avait fait un dessin
hostile au conflit en Ukraine
donc
l'éducation était toujours au cœur pour
un pouvoir politique de de la du
contrôle d'un conflit et voici c'est
c'est missiles tout à fait
impressionnant des missiles de moyenne
ou longue portée
qui sont effectivement régulièrement
montrer au cours de ce défilé de la
Place Rouge du 9 mai démonstration de
force effectivement
elle est commentaire en même temps de ce
de ce défiler
ça va pour le coup voilà on on défile
avec les très grandes armes de de
l'Arsenal on sait que c'est c'est le
recours ultime la force nucléaire et à
plusieurs reprises
Vladimir Poutine ou c'est généraux ont
laissé entendre que
l'usage de d'armes nucléaires dites
tactique par opposition aux armes
stratégiques c'est à dire qu'ils
pourraient vraiment servir dans sur le
le terrain des combats n'a pas été exclu
dans le discours mais
personne ne sait jusqu'où irait une
escalade s'il y avait vraiment un usage
de d'armes nucléaire sur le terrain et
je vous le disais
une pin aurait
indiqué à Vladimir Poutine que pour lui
l'usage de d'armes nucléaire dans ce
conflit est une ligne rouge à ne pas
franchir on s'approche de la de la fin
de défilé puisque toutes les trous de
motorisés sont passés et ensuite voilà
il y a des éléments assez rapide il y a
les autres personnes qui qui passent
devant et qui se qui bloque la place
pour chanter
est-ce qu'il y aura un défilé aérien
cette année assez vite fixé
on va vous laisser vivre ce genre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voyez paradis
qui a été justement
[Musique]
de la Place Rouge merci
plus court que notre 14 juillet comme
vous le disiez moi d'une heure 45
minutes exactement il aura duré merci
beaucoup Fabrice d'avoir été avec nous
je remercie aussi Olga notre traductrice
qui a été avec nous tout au long de ce
direct il y a des kirs en régie merci
d'avoir été avec nous on va vous laisser
la fin de ces images et on vous dit à
bientôt sur figarolive
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]